it's that time of year we're buying
gifts so what should I give a person who
might want to learn about Liberty how
about a book here are six that expanded
my brain first Road to Serfdom in this
book Frederick Hayek explains why
government intervention in the economy
leads to serfdom for writing that Hayek
was trashed dismissed ridiculed and
ignored yet in the end even defenders of
socialism came to concede that he was
right government doesn't need to
intervene wrote Hayek because a free
market like a school of fish or a flock
of birds creates a spontaneous order no
central planner can allocate resources
as well as the individual birds or
people recently an economist made this
rap video about high x ideas we don't
need a mechanic put away the wrenches
the economy's organic but now socialism
is popular again and celebrities say
things like this and we have to say yes
to socialism to the word and everything
so a road to serfdom that's a great book
to give to your socialist friends if
only they'd read this still it's
old-fashioned language can be tough
going here's a gift that explains
economics in modern language in his many
books thomas solo makes economics
simpler no charts no equations all words
plain English no grass no graphs in
basic economics he explains things like
why President Trump is wrong about trade
how much should people really worry
about the balance of trade somewhat less
than you worry about being struck by
lightning maybe someone will give this
to the president an even simpler book
that tells the story of how a clueless
lefty reporter finally woke up to the
benefits of free markets is this book
but it would be self-serving of me to
promote give me a break so I won't
mention it Atlas Shrugged is another
great introduction to creeping
government intervention
in this novel Iran predicted today's
America predicted high society parties
where rich people would vilify profits
and other things that made them rich our
ideals are higher than profit ran saw
long before I did how that kind of
ignorance and the size of government
would increase despite her characters
efforts to fight it if you believe you
may seize my property simply because you
need it well then so does any burglar
governments the burglar said ran and
this book the myth of the robber barons
takes the point further
it explains why capitalists like john d
rockefeller people who were called
robber barons were in fact not robbers
or barons they were not born rich and
they didn't get rich by robbing people
they got rich by creating better things
Rockefellers affordable kerosene
processed crude oil made the world
brighter warmer cleaner
likewise Cornelius Vanderbilt got rich
not by robbing but by making travel
faster and cheaper
Vanderbilt cut the costs of travel
filled his ships with eager passengers
it was Vanderbilt competitors who called
him a robber baron and the ignorant
media picked that up the competitors who
hated Vanderbilt didn't feel much need
to improve because they were backed by
politicians when they failed there was
almost another politician to appeal to
Vanderbilt in contrast had to serve his
customers or he would have lost his
company exactly because the so called
robber barons had their own money at
stake so they spent it carefully two
more books left consider Animal Farm
novelist George Orwell describes farm
animals who revolt against their human
master only to be ruled by new tyrants
the pigs in Orwell's book
[Music]
equally with the exception of the pigs
finally another great introduction to
freedom is this book free to choose
Milton and Rose Friedman explain in
plain English here how limiting
government creates prosperity the free
market enables people to go into any
industry they want the Nobel
prize-winning economist once said put
the federal government in charge of the
Sahara Desert in five years there'd be a
shortage of sand we somehow or other
have to find a way to prevent government
from the continuing to grow and
continuing to take over more and more
control over our lives
well we failed at bat but here at
Stossel TV we won't quit trying and
these books will help happy holidays